[Musique]
[Rires]
bonsoir bienvenue dans ce nouveau numéro
de mode d'emploi consacré aux métiers du
web sans oublier nos volets également
consacré à la formation et au
recrutement sans plus tarder voici le
sommaire chef de projet développeurs ou
encore concepteur développeur les
métiers du web sont nombreux on les
retrouve dans quasiment toutes les
entreprises
illustration au sein de la direction des
systèmes d'information du groupe la
poste à guyancourt à
saint-quentin-en-yvelines sept
organismes labellisés et sky écoles
numériques permettent de se former à ces
métiers du web par mieux au web force 3
qui débutera très prochainement à ses
formations à trappes
enfin si vous êtes à la recherche d'un
emploi ne manquez pas notre rendez vous
consacré aux entreprises de saint
quentin en yvelines qui recrutent
le groupe la poste recherche
actuellement plusieurs profils on
dénombra actuellement avec plus de 80
métiers numériques plusieurs d'entre eux
sont d'ailleurs directement liés au web
un secteur qui génère sans cesse de
nouveaux métiers
désormais toutes les grandes entreprises
disposent d'un service dédié
c'est le cas notamment de la direction
des systèmes d'information du groupe la
poste à guyancourt reportage nous sommes
d'aiguillon cours dans les locaux de la
dsi de la branche service courrier colis
et du groupe la poste
la dsi c'est la direction du système
d'information
un service qui regroupe notamment
plusieurs métiers liés au numérique
alain michel bonjour vous êtes directeur
de l'amélioration continue au sein de la
dsi alors la dsi c'est quoi alors à des
six est une entreprise qui développe les
solutions informatiques pour nos métiers
historiquement et nos clients
professionnels et depuis plus récemment
pour nos facteurs et pour les clients
particuliers
alors il ya concept un service qui
existe seulement ici ou non alors que la
direction est implanté sur trois sites
sur 50 ans donc ici bien entendu
montpellier et paris elle représente à
peu près 450 personnes dont 170 sur le
site de saint quentin en yvelines s'est
rattaché au service série et collins et
voilà vous êtes au sein de la dsi de la
branche service courrier colis donc la
branche service courrier colis c'est la
direction qu'ils fassent la branche qui
assure depuis longtemps la distribution
du courrier et des colis et qui depuis
récemment après une orientation service
donc services aux particuliers et
dont vous avez vu une pub de national de
veiller sur mes parents qui est sorti
très récemment il ya combien de métiers
différents
il ya jédir une dizaine de métiers mais
on pourrait signaler
plus précisément les directeurs de
programmes et directeur de projet les
chefs de projet les architectes les
développeurs web
stanislas elle bonjour là bonjour vous
êtes concepteur développeur scrum master
ici au sein de la dsi et l'acte quoi
consiste votre métier c'est quoi
concepteur développeur scrum master
alors concepteur développeur serait
consiste à nous développer des
fonctionnalités au sein des logiciels
pour le système d'information du groupe
la poste
scrum master c'est une activité
supplémentaire au sein de l'équipe qui
consiste à organiser l'équipe a organisé
les cycles de développement de la
communication entre les clips et les
acteurs externes alors c'est un métier
assez technique jean vizir vous avez
fait évidemment des études j'imagine
voilà pour pour faire ce métier ce que
vous voyez un petit peu nous nous parler
de votre votre parcours scolaire
oui je suis diplômée de l'école et plus
tard en tant qu'expert en ingénierie
informatique
voilà je terminais d'études en 2003 donc
c'est combien de d'années après le
comprend cinq ans d'études
qu'est ce qui vous plaît dans ce métier
alors ce qui me plaisent qui n'a
toujours plus continuer à leclerc dans
le développement informatique c'est la
belle mécanique que l'on trouve entre
les différentes fonctionnalités d'un
logiciel des différentes parties qu'il
faut faire fonctionner ensemble donc on
a même une horlogerie de techniques qui
se met en place et c'est toujours très
intéressant de voir l'ensemble
fonctionner
alors ces métiers du web sont très
recherchés par les entreprises notamment
sur notre territoire mais problème les
profils ne correspondent pas forcément
en cause le manque de formation
c'est pourquoi 13 formations viennent
d'être labellisées sky école du
numérique
c'est le cas de web force 3 à trappes
qui débutera ses cours à la fin du mois
c'est dans cette pépinière d'entreprises
à trappes que watford 3 proposera dans
quelques semaines une formation
développeur intégrateur web une
formation labellisée 50 en yvelines
école numérique elle se déroulera ici
dans cette salle encore vise à
l'insuline bonjour bonjour vous êtes le
président de web force trop alors web
pour trois ans et un réseau qui existe
depuis quatre ans combien de centres à
travers la france alors aujourd'hui il
ya une trentaine de chambres
en français
surbourg mais on est en train de
ici à trappes il sera possible donc de
suivre la formation aux développeurs
intégrateurs aux aidants très
prochainement dans l'est dans les
prochaines semaines pourquoi cette
implantation attrape alors pourquoi
cette implantation à trappes d'abord
parce que parce que notre idée c'est de
se rapprocher de plus en plus des gens
des territoires de pas avoir uniquement
des écoles dans les grandes métropoles
et que les gens aient à se déplacer
cette formation justement développeur
intégrateur web
en quoi elle consiste donc c'est une
formation de quelques mois c'est ça
l'idée c'est de dire on va pas former
des ingénieurs va former des gens
capables d'occuper un poste de travail
d'être productif immédiatement donc
c'est une formation qui est très orienté
sur les compétences dont on a besoin
tout de suite pour pouvoir travailler
qui est très en phase avec les besoins
des entreprises
gilles bonjour bonjour alors vous venez
de suivre cette formation développeur
intégrateur web
à paris iv pourquoi vous avez choisi
cette formation il ya une vingtaine
d'années j'avais suivi un cursus
dans la technique mais pas dans
l'informatique à 100%
et puis ensuite professionnellement j'ai
eu un poste d'athis franchement des
ventes donc pas tout à fait technique
et à l'occasion d'un plan social un peu
dans mon entreprise je me suis posé la
question d'un nouvel avenir
professionnel pour moi et j'ai franchi
des pas en bénéficiant de conditions de
départ et en ayant accès à cette
formation web pour toi alors est ce qu
on en parle un petit peu plus de cette
formation est effectivement je pense
deux parties l'intégration dans un
premier temps qui consiste à transformer
en visuel sous forme papier par exemple
en version électronique web
et puis le développement qui permet
d'améliorer l'expérience utilisateur par
exemple côté client avec des animations
avec des fenêtres qui vont apparaître
sous certaines conditions
et puis également le développement côté
serveur pour rendre les sites dynamiques
[Musique]
alexis bonjour là bonjour alors dans
quelques semaines vous allez venir ici
pour suivre une formation de développeur
intégrateur web avec un oued force 3 est
ce qu'on fait nous en dire plus sur sur
vous sur votre sur votre parcours partie
colère alors bon à la base j'étais
puis j'ai eu mon diplôme
ce ca paie mon brevet professionnel je
me suis rendu compte que la cuisine
c'était pas du tout fait pour moi donc
je cours après j'ai découvert grâce à
facebook web force 3 j'ai suivi
l'entretien eu lieu à la mairie à cette
formation m'a beaucoup plu est ce que
vous aviez quand même des affinités j'ai
envie de dire avec un fort match et en
fait quand j'étais au collège on a dit
que je ne pourrais pas faire de
l'informatique car j'ai une très
mauvaise moyenne en maths du combat vous
redirigera vers la cuisine mais je
l'avais avec la cuisine mais du coup je
me suis rendu compte que c'est pas du
tout ce que je voulais faire
moi je fais pas ça une des mes journées
sur un ordinateur sans décrocher je peux
passer 12h 14h sur l'ordinateur ça ne me
dérange pas du tout fin février entre 15
et 18 stagiaires suivront cette
formation développeur intégrateur web
selon les statistiques plus de 80 %
d'entre eux trouveront un emploi
rapidement
et si vous souhaitez vous lancer dans
les métiers du web voici ce qu'il faut
retenir pour devenir développeur
intégrateur web il est nécessaire
d'avoir au moins une certification
délivrée par une école le salaire pour
démarrer environ 1500 euros nets
perspectives d'évolution dans ce métier
être chef de projet le petit plus pour
durer être respectueux des délits en
début d'émission vous avez pu découvrir
avec stanislas le métier de concepteur
développeur scrum master métiers que
vous pourrez exercer après un bac +2 ou
un bac +5 informatique
la rémunération début de carrière
comptait 2500 euros nets perspectives
d'évolution dans ce métier
administrateurs de systèmes la qualité
indispensable être rigoureux et
maintenant si vous êtes à la recherche
d'un emploi prenez de quoi noter dans
cette émission les chefs d'entreprise et
les chargés de recrutement ont la parole
voici justement une offre proposée par
le groupe la poste à guyancourt
bonjour un ami chaise directeur de
l'amélioration continue au sein de la
dsi de la branche service courrier du
groupe la poste
nous avons engagé en 2010 est un vague
vaste plan de recrutement d'une de 70
personnes à peu près aujourd'hui ce plan
de recrutement n'est pas complètement
finalisé et nous recrutons encore des
développeurs développeur web
des architectes dans un mode de plus
restreint d
scrum master et des producteurs donc si
vous êtes intéressés s'ils vivent ainsi
le vélo bastareaud 5 du service rh
répondre à l'ensemble de vos questions
donc si le bastard à sylvie point le
bastard à teulat post.fr et si vous êtes
une entreprise n'hésitez pas à nous
envoyer vos offres à l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran emplois
at skype point fr cette émission touche
bientôt à sa fin mais avant nous allons
faire le tour des prochains rendez vous
qui vous attendent
alors si vous souhaitez justement en
savoir plus sur ces écoles labellisées
sky école numérique que nous avons
évoqué dans ce numéro
eh bien je dis 15 février le ski cube à
guyancourt propose un speed dating avec
les sept organismes c'est de 14h à 16h
et si vous voulez participer il faut
envoyer un mail à l'adresse qui
s'affiche en bas de votre écran
le vendredi 23 février la cité des
métiers attrape organise des ateliers
d'orientation de 9 heures à 16 heures
atelier à partir de 15 ans intitulé
découvrez vos potentiels pour trouver
votre voie professionnelle
inscription au 01 34 82 82 61
enfin notez ce rendez vous aussi vous
êtes à la recherche d'un emploi le jeudi
29 mars saint quentin en yvelines
organise en piste pour l'emploi c'est un
événement qui aura lieu de 10h à 22h au
vélodrome nationale l'entrée est
gratuite mais il faut s'inscrire sur un
site internet sur le site www.skype.com
r voilà c'est la fin de ce numéro à
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
mardi 27 février pour un nouveau mode
d'emploi consacré cette fois ci aux
métiers de l'agriculture à très bientôt
[Musique]
[Rires]